[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo willkommen zum neuen food Vlog
nach Dubai und New York folgt jetzt
London und wir starten auch direkt wir
sind hier bei Gordon ramsays Street
Pizza es ist so ein Konzept das nennt
sich bottomlitz Pizza das ist ein
anderer Beschreibung für All you can eat
und du kannst quasi einfach von dem
Teller eine Pizza deiner Wahl wählen
immer wieder so lange bis du satt bist
was machen
vorher gefragt worauf achtet ihr seid
die vegetarisch achtet ja auf halal ist
ihr Fisch und so weiter und jetzt bietet
sie uns ein eigentlich alles an was wir
essen würden und dann können wir uns das
nehmen oh mein Gott
[Musik]
ob ich das Kamera okay okay okay okay
okay
der Tag ist happy der Teig ist krass
richtig dünnen würfi und so knusprig und
geil oder Teig ist heftige schwöre ohne
Spaß das ist schon das kommt schon an
100 %
und währenddessen hat sie uns hier noch
direkt noch mal die nächste Ladung
gebracht also hier wird man auf jeden
Fall satt
ich liebe das auf Pizza
lecker ohne Ende
Beilage ist wohl genau das hier Preis
also Pommes und schicken in einer leicht
scharfen Soße
es schmeckt nicht nach Barbecue
nicht nach Barbecue nicht nach
Bratensoße oder so aber im Abgang
richtig scharf aber lecker würzig es
schmeckt nicht noch Soße das schmeckt
selbstgemacht hast du so eine leichte
Süße
Magie aber machen will das ist lecker
schmeckt aber das schaffen nicht aber
das schmeckt lecker also es schmeckt
aber nur künstlich natürlich
[Musik]
aber ich muss sagen
sei ehrlich kannst du auch Zeit lassen
oh die ist richtig gut
die ist richtig groß ist das die beste
Pizzeria gegessen hast also man kann
also die beste Pizza wann in der
politikanische Pizza was ist ja keine
napolitanische aber von den klassischen
italienischen putzen das ist echt eine
der lecker der Teig man merkt den Grieß
es ist
knusprig es ist aber nicht zu viel Teig
der Käse schmeckt sehr würzig die
Tomatensoße schmeckt homemade es
schmeckt richtig lecker ja ist echt
lecker
[Musik]
und das ist glaube ich auch keine ganze
Runde Pizza das heißt ich bin schon satt
man bezahlt hier für All you can eat ich
glaube 16 $ wenn ich mich irre also
ähm ich finde es ist nicht ganz günstig
weil für eine ganze Pizza zeig mal sonst
hast du schon hochpreisig aber dafür ist
jetzt so eine Pizza mit der Aubergine
und Pesto die probiere ich jetzt noch
frisch
gut
eigentlich war ich voll ich war so
Finnisch Haken dran aber dann kam sie
mit Ananas um die Ecke
ich liebe es ist
voll lecker
vom Gefühle hätte ich jetzt irgendwie
noch frische Kräuter drauf gemacht aber
das schmeckt schon echt oder sie sagt
auch pineapple cheese es ist glaube ich
noch mal doppelt cheese auf dieser Pizza
auf den anderen war nicht so viel Käse
drauf das war auch okay ich mag
eigentlich
einfach die hat nicht so viel drauf für
Belag so aber trotzdem schmeckt das
lecker ja
[Musik]
der Burger ist eigentlich so gut
schmecken wir müssen da vielleicht
Geschmack haben aber ich hatte stimmt
du sollst kommen
da gucke ich mir die insbesondere
negativen Bewertungen an weiter jetzt
beurteilen kann ob das quasi stimmt oder
nicht und hier schreibt Jacqueline sehr
enttäuschend sehr lange Wartezeiten auf
Pizza das kann ich nicht bestätigen weil
im Gegenteil ich war doch gar nicht
fertig mit der ersten Pizza und dann kam
sie schon mit der nächsten also es ging
richtig Schlag auf Schlag und der als
Vegetarier sowieso mehr als enttäuschen
da nur alle heilige Zeit einmal eine
Pizza ohne Fleisch Bella kommt wir
hatten ähm vier verschiedene Pizzen die
fünf wollten wir nicht ähm und drei
davon waren vegetarisch also das kann
ich jetzt nicht bestätigen Christian
schreibt dauert sehr lange bis man eine
Pizza hat all you can eat aber ich finde
das kann ich auch nicht bestätigen wie
gesagt das war es ging alles sehr
schnell es ist hochpreisig das stimmt
man zahlt vielleicht auch so ein
bisschen für Gordon Ramses Namen aber
insgesamt würde ich neuneinhalb von 10
Punkten geben das war rundum eigentlich
sehr zufrieden der Teller war ähm
was heißt nicht ganz sauber da war so
ein bisschen schmierig und ein bisschen
abgenutzt und auch kaputt ich finde das
muss man auch beachten ansonsten war es
echt lecker kann man auf jeden Fall mal
machen seven da jetzt Marke das ist
eigentlich so ein eine Art Geheimtipp
also es gibt bekannte foodmärkte und es
gibt diesen und da gibt's so geile
fußstände und einen davon den entdecken
wir jetzt das ist nämlich in einem
Crepes das oben komplett karamellisiert
ist
[Musik]
perfekt bei mir
Creme Brulee in einem Crepes und die
Oberfläche wurde gerade flambiert
eigentlich richtig simpel so eine
richtig geile Creme Brulee Kruste
jetzt probieren wir mal
[Musik]
lecker
Pudding aber alles auf Holz stehen
schmeckt immer ein paar Punkte
schlechter finde ich aber es ist lecker
oder so da drin sehr wahrscheinlich auch
zu teuer gewesen aber ist okay nur weil
sie schade finde man kann es nicht mit
dem Krebs zusammen essen also man muss
schon das Innere komplett auslesen wie
so Pudding und dann kann man eigentlich
labbriges Essen bestimmt durchgeweicht
bis dahin super
Vanillepudding Pulver ja genau wie wie
von Dr Oetker Vanillepuddingpulver also
ein bisschen Vanillegeschmack ist da
aber nicht so krass intensiv
schwarze Punkte hier siehst du gar keine
Brille sein der hätte eine schwarze
Punkte haben müssen
trotzdem in Ordnung ist
eigentlich Essen mit dem Löffel und dann
hast du eigentlich nur noch ein weich
geworden ist also es sieht eigentlich
nur cool aus
du hast kein Verpackungsmittel
geschickt bekommen
ein Döner in einer roten Waffel und ich
habe mir gedacht komm egal wir probieren
und es gibt eine geheime Soße hier und
die müssen unbedingt probieren
[Musik]
so groß wie soll ich das denn schaffen
positiv beeindruckt ich glaube das ist
glutenfreies Brot das war gut also mit
Kokos und Mandel ist mit hätte ich mir
zu umfassend vorgestellt aber es
schmeckt gut
schmeckst du jetzt unterschiedliche
normalen ja du weißt rein und das ist so
ein bisschen nee auch nicht lustig es
ist so kompakt
also guck mal jetzt ohne gemein zu sein
ne diese richtig nett gewesen wirklich
aber richtig geil
besser es ist besser aber schlecht aber
es schmeckt besser
Instagram
also ganz ehrlich so also in Deutschland
also ich glaube
[Musik]
sind wir hier vom donatellier vergessen
zuckerschuh ne den toten Tier
[Musik]
ich glaube jetzt wisst ihr was ich meine
oder also ist schon wo du nach Kunst
also ihr Bestseller ist ähm pistazia da
ist oben drüber noch so ein Keks denke
der ist auch gefüllt ich weiß nicht
direkt mal rein
und guck mal
also
heftig ich muss noch mal beißen
oh mein Gott
Videos
allein dieser Kekse oben drüber und
diese Pistazie in dieser Pistazien
Pudding oder Ganache was auch immer es
ist schmeckt richtig geil es kam noch
keine Füllung durch vielleicht ist doch
keine Füllung drin stattdessen ist die
Füllung oben drüber was ich gar nicht
schlimm finden würde weil ich glaube
sonst ist auch einfach zu viel
Donuts also kein
bestes mal das ist einfach jede
Komponente schmeckt sehr frisch sehr
frisch schmeckt nicht fettig es ist ja
aufgebacken also frittiert es ist doch
eine Füllung drin ich hätte noch mehr
weiß müssen
ich glaube das eine Basic Creme in den
ganzen Donuts drin ist und das Coaching
und das Topping einfach hat das ist der
Geschmack on top aber innen drin sind
die immer gleich
richtig gut
das ist auf jeden Fall gute
bessere eklige war kein Geschmack der
schmeckt wirklich gut und der Keks ist
auch richtig lecker der ist einfach nur
frisch gebackene der schmeckt wieder als
würde ich den zu Hause selber gebacken
haben
so ein leicht zitronigen Beigeschmack
ohne Spaß das ist lecker kannst ja habe
ich mir gerade auch gedacht
da oben ist irgendwas
karamellisiertes ich glaube das ist so
ein
nein
drei Sekunden Regel ich weiß rein egal
ich trinke Schwarzkümmel mein
Immunsystem ist gut
aber er kann sich Brot haben weil die
ganze Füllung die eigentlich drin ist
wieso oben drüber und die ist jetzt weg
aber
gewesen
ich muss sagen ohne dieses Topping ist
da echt wenig Geschmack es ist schon
das Video rein Geschwister vielleicht
wir sind irgendwie keine Ahnung ich muss
sagen nur mit diesem geilen Topping
schmeckt ja auch vollkommen ohne dieses
Topping es ist ein bisschen langweilig
auch wenn es ein sehr sehr frischer und
lecker
hätte sein können aber nur das Topping
wie gesagt drauf hast dann ist es
perfekt dann ist auch 10 %. okay ich
glaube hier ist irgendwas schief
gelaufen beim Befüllen weil das ist echt
wenig ich glaube nicht dass das so
gewollt war
also das war glaube
passieren also jetzt auch einen Kaffee
am Essen alles Mensch
[Musik]